Nó này, mình sau tháng 1 năm 2018, tông tin từ công an tỉnh đồng này.
Đân vị vừa tổng đặt cứ định khởi tổ bị cân và lệnh cấm đi khỏi nơi kêu trụ đối với vũ hoàng phút.
Xin năm 2018, chú sá quang thiệt tính ninh bình về tội, lây giới chật tự công cộp.
Vũ hoàng phủ là tù sĩ và sáo với pháp sàng tích mình vân.
Đông thời là chủ tại khoản vạn xa hội tích tốt phủ tự với khoản vô phẩy hai chữ về thân sỏi,
là canya có sự an hưởng lớn trên không dân nào.
Tuy nhiên, ra nhận tức pháp lợp còn hạn xí, vũ hoàng phủ đã có những hình ví thiếu khiểm soát.
Qua sinh là viên với các quan công an, sau khi được dự đề đủ về quyền và nghĩa vụ của bạn thân.
Lý ra bị khởi tổ cũng như các quy định pháp lợp có liên quan, vũ hoàng phủ đã khai báo thình khình.
Thôi dẫn hình vì pháp lợp và nhận tức được những hộ quả màn vi của mình đã gây ra đối với xa hội.
Chứ đó, nè mình hai thân tắm năm 2019 tại tỏ an in zinh tỉnh đồng này,
vô hoàng phủ có hình ví sử dụ cùng an lào và đánh bị cáo đưa qua trung trong lúc lượng gánh xa hỗ trợ tư pháp đang áp sài bị cáo dự khỏi phòng sế sử.
Sư việc sế giá khiến cho phía toàn bị náo lạc, người cạnh trường hoàn động và sự tương nghiêm của tỏ an in zinh,
anh hưởng miếng trọng đến tình hình an in chịch tự tại nị phương.
Nè, hay mì hai tháng 12 năm 2019, các quan cánh xa đời trà công an tỉnh đồng này đã hử tổ vụ an in xử,
hợi tổ bị cạnh đời với vô hoàn phủ về những bí gây dụ chịch tự công không.